[Musik]
ale etwas geht ab das heißt sie zu hält
vettel kommen beim neuen videos na ja
keine ahnung was dort auf jeden fall
bevor es losgeht wollte ich noch mal
schnell darauf hinweisen
der märz ist online heute ab 14 uhr als
es eben online gegangen erster linie der
beschreibung stadt auf jeden fall mal
rein ins gold ein bisschen durch wenn
ich was gefällt könnt ihr gerne
zuschlagen als wenn ihr mich irgendwie
unterstützen wollt oder so dann wäre das
eine möglichkeit als natürlich nur wenn
ihr mich cool findet und was gefällt und
will ich das gar nicht als erste lenkt
in der video beschreibung einfach mal
kurz vorbeischauen
wirklich freuen ansonsten geht es los
mit dem video
ich glaube ich muss mich hinsetzen ich
hab mir das macht es dem stehen aber
irgendwie fühlt man sich durch wird auf
jeden fall draußen bleiben deswegen
setze ich mich jetzt hier hin
scheiße jetzt muss mit stativ form das
gefecht ist so leute was geht ab jetzt
hier sein stativ gebaut das wird sie die
soviel zum thema match wie gesagt du
nicht mehr geld freuen wenn immer
reinschaut aber das sollte es auch mal
sein mit der werbung ist mir heute was
überlegt was ich eigentlich so von sich
aus gar nicht machen wollte oder machen
würde aber ich habe letztlich wieder
hochgeladen wo ich gesagt hab ja das
augen vogel macht der herbst macht der
vogel cook zu als cool und wieder nicht
gesagt habe ich bin ich an meiner
freundin zusammen und so was alles und
daraufhin haben mir viele geschrieben
alex vega total schlecht ich bin meinem
freund meiner freundin zusammen was soll
ich machen sagt man mal irgendwie geht
mal ein paar tipps wo ich mir denke ich
bin jetzt nicht dein freund oder so der
dir da helfen kann da gehst am besten zu
deiner freundin oder sein freund
kollegen keine ahnung aber ich hab mir
jetzt mal gedacht so an sich bin ich
immer gesagt alex du musst ein vorbild
sein du darfst nicht shisha rauchen
du darfst nicht dass du darfst nicht
weniger als gestern auf jeden fall hab
mir gedacht da youtuber vorbilder sind
zum teil zum teil auf er nicht ich bin
jetzt auf jeden fall war ein bisschen
vorbild sein und mit diesem video
vielleicht an die die halt mich gefragt
habe oder generell an alle die es
interessiert ich kann sagen so
bin jetzt mal so der kleinsten ich hab
da so ein paar erfahrungen gesammelt in
meinem leben und sonst sitzt oder so wie
man damit umgehen kann wenn man halt
nicht mehr mit seiner ersten freundin
ersten freund zusammen ist kann ich
jetzt einfach mal sagen auch wenn es
eigentlich nicht so mein lieblings
content ist einmalig haben für das video
jetzt gar keine gedanken gemacht es sind
einfach so meine meine tipps die ich zu
jedem meiner freunde auch sagen würde
ich gehe einfach mal davon aus euren
ersten freunde der ersten freundin so
und irgendwann ist das halt vorbei man
denkt natürlich so vor allem an jetzt 14
as 5
bei uns wird das sucht immer halten so
ich kann das ja selber aber eigentlich
ich glaube in 95% bis 80 prozent der
fälle ist derzeit nicht so dann ist
jedoch vorbei und dann hängt man sich so
ist es mein leben vorbei das macht alles
keinen sinn mehr oder so und so eine
welt bricht zusammen
wie gesagt kann ich selber und es gibt
bis zum jetzt ganz viele die das video
genau zu diesem zeitpunkt schauen wo sie
sich gerade denken oder wo man dann halt
bei youtube eigene blogs kann ich
dagegen tun das ist mir so schlecht
jedenfalls erstmal ganz grob gesagt so
mit der zeit wird das auf jeden fall
besser das video zeigt was ich sagen
kann
ihr dürft nicht denken so auf es ist das
vorbei ich kann nie wieder jemand
anderes haben oder ich werde nie wieder
jemand anderes haben war ich will nur
diese personen haben das ist toll der
dumme gedanken weil man mehr als ich
kann mich zu 100 prozent versichern
mit der zeit es ist 40 so da denkt man
so auch jetzt ist ein neues coupé mit zu
denken
so werde es jetzt wirklich die richtige
person für uns gewesen dann wärt ihr
eigentlich für immer zusammen geblieben
aber es war auf keinen fall die richtige
person das ist auch wirklich so weiß
jetzt die erste große liebe ist kann
natürlich heißen so ist die richtige
person lanciert sich zeigen aber meinten
es ist nicht so als dürfe auf keinen
fall so jetzt komplett euch nur
zurückziehen in euer zimmer gehen und so
nix machen nicht raus nur weil das ist
total schlecht weil ich kann euch sagen
die trauriger ihr seid oder je mehr man
immer noch fällt desto schwieriger ist
es dann halt auch da wieder rauszukommen
und es ist wirklich so irgendwann sei es
jetzt schon in zwei monaten oder sei es
erst in zwei jahren oder so ist dann
plötzlich wieder irgendjemand anderes da
der ein noch viel glücklicher macht als
man damals war mit seiner ersten
freundin also ja das gehört halt einfach
im leben dazu dass man vor allem mit
fünf dann auch mal auf die fresse fliegt
und märkte
das ist jetzt halt so und was hat auch
ganz wichtig ist
für mich was so wichtig so man sollst
oder ich konzentriere mich eigentlich
nur so voll auf mich zu ich weiß es kann
sich das sagen soll dass es nicht ganz
so es ist wichtig dass ihr euch einfach
nur auf mich konzentriert und so das
macht was ihr wollt und halt wirklich so
ein bisschen egoistisch zeit kann man
eigentlich schon so sagen wenn man sich
in der zweiten wechselzone auf sich
konzentriert das macht was man selber
feiert dann fällt auch leichter dieses
andere ausländer ich mal einig kann man
dazu so viele sachen sagen die mir jetzt
gerade aber irgendwie ich weiß gar nicht
wie ich das zu überbringen soll also
grob zusammengefasst das leben geht auf
jeden fall weiter auch wenn ich dieses
gefühl liebe zeit sei es aber wenn es
nicht passt dann passt nicht weil so
jetzt gesehen er oder sie hat euch
gesagt ja ich lieb dich nicht mehr da
kann man dann ganz ehrlich auch nicht
zwingend machen da braucht jetzt nicht
hinterherrennen oder sonst was machen
entweder diese person meld dich
irgendwann wieder bei euch weil sie dann
plötzlich doch wieder gefühl hat oder
sowas aber geht einfach davon aus dass
es nicht so ist geht einfach vom
schlimmsten aus das ist eigentlich das
sinnvollste was man machen kann geht
davon aus dass jetzt nie wieder was
werden konzentriert euch auf euch macht
das zur of warcraft wir draußen mit
freunden oder so aber fällt da nicht
immer noch weil das ist halt scheiße zu
als ich spreche aus erfahrung und zu 100
prozent wird euch wenn es euch jetzt
gerade mal ein zwei wochen scheint sich
jetzt auch monaten drei monaten sagen
wir mal natürlich auch bei jedem anders
gehts euch wieder deutlich besser planen
verschwindet so ab und zu vielleicht
noch ein gedanke an diese person
aber das gehört halt dazu das kann man
auch nicht vermeiden nur das waren du
erst mal meine gedanken dazu zu allen
die mir halt so was geschrieben haben
die hat nicht wussten was jetzt machen
wollen geht zu ihrer freundin redet mit
der darüber aber ich bin auch nicht so
der richtige ansprechpartner für jeden
ich meine ich mache nur youtube videos
aber es geht natürlich auch an alle die
jetzt vielleicht an ihren freund eine
freundin hatten oder keine ahnung die
jetzt vielleicht gerade den ersten zeug
oder freunden haben
ich hoffe es hältst du immer aber wenn
es nicht so ist dann kopf hoch leben
geht weiter und denkt an das was ich
immer gesagt für uns ganz wichtig ich
hoffe ich hab jetzt einigermaßen gut
rübergebracht
abgesehen vom thema kauft einen quatsch
da kann man echt mal vorbeischauen also
ganz oben in der video beschreibung ich
will auch gar nicht so viel werbung
machen
aber das jetzt online und ich bin voll
stolz zurück wir sehen uns dienstag
wieder dienstags kommt neues video
capture und instagram und wenn ich
irgendwas fragen wollt dann fragt mich
das gameplay instagram ich lebe ja
wirklich viele sachen durch wäre mir zu
einem punkt aber irgendwas was ihr
schreibt was gutes einfällt was von auf
antworten kann antwort ich gerne
ansonsten bin ich wie viele es auch
nicht so der richtige ansprechpartner
wie schon gesagt es mache nur user
videos geht man mit freunden oder sogar
zwei kreist seit dem video armee
bestimmt ungelogen 70 leichter zu
drücken
ich bin gerade auch in dem was ich mache
mir geht also weiter
wir sehen uns kaufen